[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous suivre en
direct sur figaro live on attend vos
points de vue pour alimenter nos thèmes
du jour est aujourd'hui avec nous pour
débattre lucile schmid bonjour lucile
vous êtes vice présidente de la
fondation la fabrique écologique vous
est également membre du conseil de
rédaction de la revue esprit à ce titre
je signale que vous avez coordonné le
dernier numéro de la revue le numéro
d'avril dont on peut voir en ce moment
la couverture à l'image vous avez signé
également l'article l'état et nous fasse
avoue vincent trémolet bonjour vincent
vous êtes vous alors j'ai létale c'est
un programme du président a cessé de lui
si vous êtes je le rappelle directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du figaro et
vous venez faire vous venez de faire
publier éloge de la politique chez
tallandier merci à tous les deux d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui
le président de la république emmanuel
macron a pris la parole une nouvelle
fois hier soir pour annoncer de
nouvelles mesures qui doivent freiner la
probable la propagation du virus
qu'ovide 19 sur le territoire près de 31
millions de téléspectateurs ont regardé
son intervention allez vous respectez
les nouvelles mesures annoncées pas il
ya par emmanuel macron hier c'est la
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter et
on reviendra sur votre participation à
la fin de ce premier débat
alors à tous les deux lucile et vincent
j'ai d'abord envie vous demander à l'un
et l'autre ce que vous avez pensé de
cette intervention des manuels macro
hier soir lucile moi j'ai apprécié le
contenu de ce qu'a dit le président de
la république c'est à dire qu'il ait
parlé de respiration qu'il ait parlé
d'espoir qu'il ait parlé de vaccination
j'ai trouvé que c'était bienvenu après
je pense qu'il faut que je sois courte
pour cette première intervention j'ai
beaucoup de choses à dire mais j'ai
trouvé que son style était étrangement
daté et alors qu'on a un très jeune
président de la république il ya quelque
chose d'extraordinairement archaïque
dans la façon dont en france le
président de la république s'adresse à
nous comme si nous étions des enfants et
7 cette question de ce jeune
ce jeune président la république qui
prend cette attitude paternelle avec son
costume bleu marine
tout en termes de communication
politique il ya quelque chose qui dans
cette mondialisation convient et red hat
et vous trouvez que d'autres chefs
d'état sont plus moderne que lui écoutez
évidemment parle tout le temps de
l'allemagne parce qu'on est obsédé par
l'allemagne mais ce qui est clair c'est
quand gala merkel elle met en scène
entre une communication collective qui
me semblent intéressantes et ça ne veut
pas dire qu'elles prennent pas des
responsabilités mais ça permet aussi de
se protéger c'est à dire quand on est
tout le temps en première ligne pour le
président de la république ça rend
parfois les choses compliquées alors
comme moi je le répète j'ai apprécié le
contenu de ce qu'il a dit et l'archaïsme
dont vous parlez c'est cette espèce de
mise à distance imposée par la fonction
et la façon dont ils énoncent je pense
qu'il ya un problème institutionnel on
est pas rendre emmanuel macron
responsable de la constitution de la
vème république son caractère gaullien
mais il ya aussi peut-être cette façon
dont on pourrait partager les voies du
pouvoir pourquoi pas sans affaiblir la
voix présidentielle est au fond c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui au parlement et
cette espèce de récriminations que je
trouve personnellement très maladroite
de la part de certains mais qui peut
reposer sur du factuel
donc ça me semble être un élément à
prendre en considération
vincent très drôle et qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé de cette intervention cette
énième intervention du comme moi je les
trouvais contraintes dans la forme c'est
à dire qu'on sentait que
emmanuel macron est à contre emploi et
qu'ils disaient ce qu'ils n'avaient pas
envie de dire et d'ailleurs les passages
notamment celui sur l'école le préalable
avant qu'ils disent qu'ils aient fermé
les écoles expliquant que les gones
s'étaient pas négociable de douchez à
l'école là il n'était pas mauvais parce
qu'on retrouvait ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment donc moi j'ai trouvé que dans
le fond de cette intervention il y avait
un problème et une déception c'est qu'il
il a cédé au fait il a cédé à une
pression très forte c'était pas facile
de ne pas y céder sur toute cette
pression très forte qui l'unît en gros
dés des mandarins de l'ap-hp avait pour
objet les motifs des choses tragiques
puisque c'était la vie des gens mais
ensuite d'autres médecins ont expliqué
que ce tri des malades qui avait été
invoquée était discutable et il me
semble qu'il restait une voie de passage
avec peut-être un certain nombre de
restrictions c'est à dire l'extension du
confinement à la france entière mais que
les écoles auraient pu être épargnées
parce que quand on nous dit c'est quatre
jours d'école supprimer c'est pas vrai
les écoles vont fermer un mois
psychologiquement pour les parents et
les enfants c'est un retour un an avant
et c'est la possibilité d'une césure
qu'on avait qui avait disparu c'est à
dire que depuis le 11 mai les écoles
n'ont jamais fermé et à partir du moment
où on dit ce temps cette chose moi ça
m'a inquiété au fait ce qui commence
maintenant ce que je commence à trouver
préoccupant c'est la façon dont on
dispose d'éléments qui nous dépasse
l'école nous dépasse la démocratie nous
dépasserons a parlé la dernière fois sur
les les élections et on a l'impression
maintenant que il suffit d'ajuster comme
sur une console un certain nombre de
choses pour les obtenir
je regrette je regrette cette décision
je pense qu emmanuel macron la regrette
lui-même qui l'a prise à contrecoeur
jean michel blanquer bien entendu qui
jusqu'à lundi matin twitté le clip des
pink floyd détourné 10 ans nous
détestons l'école à la maison voilà et
jeu il me semble que pour lui
politiquement c'est quand même la fin
d'une exception d'une chose qu'il avait
distingué par rapport aux autres chefs
d'état c'est qu'il avait une constante
c'était ça mais je vous propose de vous
parce qu'on va passer à la suite je vous
propose qu'on revient dans quelques
secondes justement sur ces mesures
annoncées hier soir par le président de
la république
les cinq mesures phares qui ont été
prises
ces règles seront étendues à tout le
territoire métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile
nous allons fermer durant trois semaines
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
des lycées à partir du 16 avril
les premiers rendez vous seront accordés
aux personnes qui ont entre 60 et 70 ans
dès la mi mai nous recommencerons à
ouvrir avec des règles strictes certains
lieux de culture nous autoriserons sous
conditions l'ouverture de terrasses
bakbone consulting pour le figaro et
france info paru ce matin plus de sept
français sur dix soutiennent les règles
annoncées mercredi par emmanuel macron
mais 46% d'entre eux n'ont pas
l'intention de les respecter
scrupuleusement
on reviendra sur / ce paradoxe est qu
est ce que vous pensez de ces nouvelles
règles vous parliez vincent de ces
mesures de fermeture d'école est ce qu
elles sont malgré tout bien venu ces
mesures il ya un vrai sujet par rapport
à ce que 10 à 20 cents sur les écoles
c'est que beaucoup de professeurs
étaient quand même en train de dire
qu'ils étaient dans des lieux de
contamination et le fait de ne pas avoir
vacciné les professeurs en priorité est
sans doute à l'amp et ça s'est fait
ailleurs et je pense que si on avait
vacciné les professeurs peut-être qu'on
aurait pu maintenir les écoles ouvertes
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'il ya pas que les
élèves et les enfants et les parents il
ya aussi les ça c'était un vrai enjeu
après moi je pense valérie pécresse
avait dit
sur la semaine dernière l'a répété ce
matin parce qu'elle est contente d'avoir
été la première à l'annoncer ça c'est le
jeu politique
elle avait dit qu'il faudrait sans doute
avancé les vacances moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était une bonne idée et je suis mère
de famille railleur et je trouve que ça
a été plutôt bien pris part en tout cas
certains enfants
qu'ils ont l'impression que du coup
alors pas trop d'écoles c'est à dire que
le sujet c'est au fond de mettre un
horizon sûr que si on met un horizon et
emmanuel macron a fait très attention à
le dire parce que comme vous venez de le
dire vincent il était contraint lui le
voulait m'a fermé en ce sens mais il a
quand même parlé de respiration il a dit
que c'était pour trois semaines
donc tout ça aide psychologiquement je
crois à ceux à se séparer du premier
confinement ou moi je me rappelle
combien ça avait été extrêmement
difficile pour tous les jeunes qui
restent à la maison qui aura pris au fil
de l'eau qu'il ne passerait pas leur
examen par exemple et il a été répété je
crois par le premier ministre où ça a
été dit assez rapidement que par exemple
les concours se tiendrait enfin il ya
des choses qui ont été marqués comme
référent pour montrer qu'on n'était plus
dans un confinement qui allait durer
c'est ça que j'ai retenu c'est qu'il y
avait quelque chose mais c'est le pari
la stratégie vaccinale donc c'est là
qu'on va ensuite oui et puis il ya
chardon bleu un qui nous dit emmanuel un
qu'on aurait dû faire un coup d'éclat
est libérées tout ça je sais pas si
chardons bleus n'est pas un peu excessif
mais voilà mais en revanche je pense
qu'il ya un adage qu'on peut maintenant
dire après un an de
de crise c'est que confinement on sait
quand on y rentre on sait pas quand on
en sort est donc là on fixe des dates
mais le premier confinement l'année
dernière il devait durer 15 jours il a
duré quasiment deux mois
et là il va en fait les écoles pour les
collégiens et les lycéens vous fermer
pendant un mois et il y aura une
inégalité très importante
d'abord dans les familles on peut être
aidé ou pas et ensuite dans selon
l'école lui c'est dans lequel vous êtes
parce que si vous êtes dans un lycée
privé performant
maintenant ça fonctionne puis si vous
êtes dans un lycée plus difficile est ce
qu'il y aura cours est ce que les gens
suivront les cours est ce que les profs
3 trouveront leurs élèves s qui se
connecteront pas moi je pense que le
télé enseignement est une imposture
qu'on l'a vu que ça peut marcher de
façon extrêmement rares au milieu de
structure forte c'est-à-dire une école
forte avec peut-être des familles qui
aident mais que ça n'est pas vrai qu'on
va reproduire paraîtront un écran
interposé ce qui est l'enseignement dans
une classe donc il me semble que que ce
choix et est difficile et à mon avis il
aurait pu enfin c'est là où moi j'ai un
regret c'est que pourquoi at il été pris
est ce qu'il a été pris pour des raisons
sanitaires et si on en a la preuve très
bien mais peut-être qu'il a été pris
pour des raisons politiques
parce qu'il y avait à la fois une
pression syndicale sur blanc caire une
pression d'un certain nombre de médecins
sur macron toute l'opposition qui disait
il va il va pas assez loin valérie
pécresse et c'est sans que l'on sache
vraiment finalement si cette fermeture
quatre jours on parlait que
judiciaire à venir voilà donc on revient
toujours à des choses que l'on a déjà
dit ici c'est à dire que les nécessités
administrative le risque pénal
l'ambition politique vient se joindre à
une nécessité sanitaire et on ne sait
plus la part de quelle est la part de
l'un ou de l'autre dans ces histoires et
même dans le confinement aujourd'hui on
ne sait plus si le confinement est une
décision qui a pour but d'apaiser de
rassurer ou si elle a vraiment
l'efficacité qu'elle pouvait avoir
il y à il ya un an parce qu'en fait il
ya un an et après je vous laisse la
parole le confinement était fondée sur
le consentement de tous les français qui
avaient peur et le confinement qui
marche et le plus strictes possibles et
moi ça pour le coup j'en suis convaincu
il est impossible à installer
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible des
français de l'acceptable y adhéreront
plus ce qui me frappe c'est par rapport
au confinement qu' il soit pas assez dit
que c'est un enfermement et qu'en fait
et toutes ces petites îles qu'on voit
sur les chaînes d'information continue
qui disent souvent fermé tout le monde
et cette question de la santé mentale
qui dieu merci maintenant est abordé un
peu plus explicitement comme un vrai
sujet c'est à dire que l on dit il ya
les libertés publiques mais il ya aussi
l'enfermement psychologique ya pas
seulement une question de libertés
publiques et je suis assez frappé
effectivement de voir le consensus des
épidémiologistes des médecins et c'est
sur cette question de l'enfermement
alors même que je pense qu'il ya un coût
évidemment social très important là
dessus après la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire par rapport à emmanuel
macron et son intervention c'est qu'il
ya quelque chose qui est apparue
progressivement c'est quand même par
rapport à l'année dernière
c'est quand même qu'un - du bri il ya
une modestie que même si comme je le
disais le style le costume bleu marine
et c'est bon c'est mais il ya moins du
bri il ya donc cette modestie yahoo dans
sa naissance et une route au nord
auraient été commises voilà moi j'ai
trouvé ça quand même intéressant et je
pense que c'est étonnant que ce soit pas
davantage
je passe il faut le saluer mais en tout
cas reconnaître que les choses ont
changé en termes de communication et
puis il ya il ya cette espèce de ligne
qui maintient on sait ce qu'ils pensent
quand on sait qu'ils pensent que la
question de la respiration la liberté
d'un montante et là dessus moi je suis
je suis à 100% d'accord avec lui et je
pense que ça il faut le répéter parce
que les commentateurs je trouve sont
beaucoup trop en train de dire il a tort
il faut en faire mais on est quand même
dans une espèce de truc
je trouve bizarre alors vous parlez des
commentateurs justement qui sont
totalement opposés ou en tout cas qui
sont mécontentes une intervention d'hier
il ya une phrase qui a beaucoup d'effet
sur les réseaux sociaux en particulier
quand il a dit nous avons tout fait pour
prendre ses décisions le plus tard
possible
est-ce que ça n'est pas un aveu d'échec
un constat d'échec ou l'aveu que la
décision a été prise effectivement trop
tard ça moi je crois pas du tout je
pense que si les décisions avaient été
prises telles que vous voulez construit
scientifique et un certain nombre de
petits vous parlez lui s'il on aurait
été confiné le 1er février nous serions
encore confiné à l'époque il n'y avait
pas de vaccin donc oui et puis là là la
clé delà de la pensée la vision de ces
gens qui considèrent qu'on ne ferme pas
assez c'est le confinement préventif
c'est à dire que on est enfermé jusqu'à
ce qu'on puisse sortir sans aucun risque
or c'est ça exige j'entendais williams
d'abord c'est un directeur de l'alsh de
directeur général de la santé qui disait
il ya une semaine il faut enfermer
pendant deux mois de façon stricte et
après les gens pour en sortir donc en
fait il là il ya une forme du bri
vraiment et il yal espèce de rêve de
maîtriser quelque chose qui n'arrive pas
à attraper depuis un an qu'ils ce virus
alors qu'à mon avis emmanuel macron à la
sagesse de dire désormais on va vivre
quand il dit on va vivre avec c'est ça
mais ce débat va se poursuivre encore
avec la vaccination parce que si l'on
entend bien ce que disent les uns et les
autres
macron et certains dans dans son
gouvernement veulent ajuster les
ouvertures à la vaccination en gros une
fois que toutes les personnes
vulnérables sont vaccinés il y aura
moins de monde à l'hôpital et on peut
recommencer à réouvrir mais il ya en
face d'autres gens dont vivait en qui
disent non il faut que tout le monde
soit vacciné parce qu'on sait pas si
jamais il ya un variant si jamais on
relâche les gestes et c est donc cette
cette bataille ou macron a dû faire un
retrait tactique que moi
ce qui me désole hier va continuer elle
n'est pas du tout terminé et le problème
est là c'est un problème de gouvernance
c'est qu'elle se passe à l'intérieur
même de son gouvernement c'est à dire
qu'il a l'air parfois de subir la
pression et administratifs de jean
castex et sanitaires d'olivier ferrand
alors que c'est plutôt lui qui devrait
décider plutôt que ça c'est intéressant
parce que ça rejoint ce que je disais au
début de notre échange sur le fait qu'il
faudrait à mettre en place une
communication politique
je sais pas si elle est plus
transparente même la plus collective qui
nous permettrait de comprendre qu'il
n'ya pas qu emmanuel macron qui décident
parce que c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe évidemment on en parlera dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission a
bondi cas je pense que quelque part la
solitude de la communication
présidentielle peut affaiblir le
président de la république libre nous
dit en tant que citoyen c'est notre
devoir de respecter ces mesures à gisèle
ajoute nous n'avons pas le choix il le
faut pour se protéger ou protéger les
autres et se sortir de cette mélasse et
ça me fait penser qu'on n'est pas
revenue sur ce paradoxe de ce sondage
aux hawks a paru ce matin je le disais
46% des français n'ont pas l'intention
de respecter scrupuleusement les règles
annoncées hier soir par le chef de
l'état alors qu'ils sont plus de 7 sur
10 a estimé qu'elles sont bien et à les
soutenir
est ce que vous comprenez cette volonté
de s'affranchir des règles alors que
c'est peut-être précisément ce
non-respect des mesures qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui virus se propage
non mais il ya quand même cette histoire
de scrupuleusement et quand même un peu
il faut savoir comment on l'entend c'est
à dire que il ya en permanence
maintenant depuis quelques semaines et
c'est bienvenu un appel à la
responsabilité ça a été redit ça a été
redit hier donc la question de la
responsabilité c'est vous entends en
votre âme et conscience
est ce que vous êtes capable de
comprendre qu'est ce que ça signifie sur
le plan sanitaire sur le fait d'exposer
les autres sur le fait de vous exposez
vous même
donc si c'est scrupuleusement ça veut
dire faire toujours son attestation
ça n'a plus de sens puisque toute façon
il ya plus d'attestation donc moi je
crois que l'histoire de scrupuleusement
personnellement je le comprends comme
quelque chose qui sans doute un peu
déphasé par rapport au confinement tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui où je crois que
l'appel à la responsabilité plus fort où
je crois qu'on a une marge de manoeuvre
c'est à dire faire 10 km 5 je le dis
franchement cilic scrupuleusement ses
comptes et qu'on fait neuf qui met neuf
et non pas 10 km 5 mois je suis pas sûr
d'être prêt scrupuleuses
et je pense que cette question elle doit
se gérer par rapport à ce qu'on est ce
que sont ce qu'ils sont devenus cultes
voilà donc là je crois que c'est assez
cohérent en fait aux docks ça c'est à
dire que on pense que c'est bien et on
essaye d'imaginer qu'est ce que c'est
que la responsabilité sans penser sans
cesse à l'état policier ya pas de côté
et pas de côté on peut se permettre
quelques entorses on va dire ah oui mais
c'est aux mesures sanitaires dans la
limite je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est il faut pas que c'est la peur que
derrière chaque pilier dans la rue il ya
un policier qui va vous va sortir et
vous contrôlez je crois que le fait par
exemple d'avoir dit on contrôlera mois
mais on contrôlera plus sévèrement quand
vous êtes en infraction
ça c'est ça aussi qui se passe c'est à
dire que vous êtes quelqu'un d'équilibré
d'adultes comme dit vincent et du coup
vous savez où sont les choses ça fait un
an vous devriez en local savoir il ya
cette espèce de pédagogie aussi de ce
qu'il faut une amie a prise il ya une
chose qui qu'on apprenait petit qui
était la lettre et l'esprit quand y
avait une règle
il ya là il ya une règle on la suit à la
lettre et puis il ya un moment il ya
l'esprit de la règle
et là c'est exactement ça et donc le
fait d'aller si il ya un an siona les à
2 km ou en novembre si on allait à deux
kilomètres c'était pas bien
et aujourd'hui si on y va de kilomètres
c'est bien donc ça veut dire qu'on ne
veuille il ya en novembre on aurait été
contaminé là on aura peut être contaminé
c'est grotesque
le fait qu'on puisse pas acheter des
lego alors qu'on peut faire c'est ce
n'est pas d'ordre sanitaire c'est
d'ordre administratif ça donc moi il me
semble que ça c'est ça que veulent dire
les électeurs ensuite les pardons les
sondés ensuite moi il ya quand même
quelque chose qu'il faut dire c'est que
ceux qui parlent le plus de ces règles
c'est à dire les politiques
les médecins que l'on voit sur les
plateaux les commentateurs les
journalistes dont je fais partie sont
des gens qui ne vivent pas ils en sont
exonérés voilà ils en sont exonérés pas
parce que ils ont une vie
professionnelle qui fait qu'ils rendent
rue gassion ils n'ont pas de couvre feu
les politiques continuent à avoir une
vie très active ils ont des rendez vous
etc et donc ils font des choses en
vision comme nous tous comme tout le
monde mais bon et donc je trouve qu'il
faut faire attention en ce que se
développe une espèce de vue élitaire du
confinement dix ans mais quand même là
j'entendais castex qui dit les
irresponsables mais les irresponsables
qui sont enfermés dans des appartements
et qui veulent sortir sur les quais
parce qu'ils sont dans un tout petit
truc et qui fait 25 degrés ne sont pas
dans la même situation que que ceux qui
ont pris cette décision je pense que la
proposition de raymond aron qui consiste
à dire quand un ministre est une
décision faut se mettre à sa place doit
être renversée 50 amis nice prend la
décision
il doit aussi de mettre à sa place de
celui qui va la subir et là c'est
peut-être pas toujours le cas
allez-vous respecter les mesures les
nouvelles mesures annoncées hier par
émail même par emmanuel macron alors on
va regarder votre participation et vous
êtes 59% à nourrice à nous répondre que
oui vous allez être respectueux de ces
nouvelles règles en passe tout de suite
au deuxième débat avec cette question la
crise du coc vide 19 mai tel à l'épreuve
la démocratie en france la question vous
est posée sur twitter et je relaierai
votre participation à la fin de
l'émission
l'assemblée nationale a approuvé ce
jeudi les nouvelles restrictions
annoncées par emmanuel macron mais la
quasi-totalité des oppositions ont
boycotté le scrutin en dénonçant je cite
une mascarade
je vous propose de regarder deux
interventions phare entendu ce matin à
l'assemblée
mais quel conseil municipal se
permettrait de voter sur les décisions
qui ont déjà été adoptés qui ont déjà
été édités
voilà la réalité la démocratie c'est la
décision ici et pas à côté
très clairement on ne participera pas
cette mascarade démocratique et à ce
simulacre de consultation
ici on est là pour voter la loi pas pour
adouber la parole jupitérienne d'un
oracle à la dation oudin et
physiologiste suprême le vote n'aura
aucune conséquence carmel si nous
venions à voter non tous unis pour une
fois cela ne changerait rien la
responsabilité du gouvernement n'est pas
engagée par ce vote
oui c'est un mauvais poisson d'avril est
le poisson d'avril comme tous les
poisson pourrit par la tête
le premier ministre jean castex s'est
exprimé à son tour et a vivement
critiqué les interventions successives
des chefs de groupe à l'assemblée qui
avait fustigé la conduite de la crise
par l'exécutif on écoute j'ai entendu
j'ai beaucoup d'intervenants l'idée que
finalement elle serait trop tardive
elle serait tu insuffisances ton mais
bien c'est votre droit d'exprimer cela
aujourd'hui
nous parlions des prog hâtive du
parlement mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous écoute
mardi après mardi et aujourd'hui voilà
que nous serions qu'on nous autorise le
formidable
bref sans doute preuve sans doute que
nous sommes au juste milieu a mis les
critiques exprimées par l'opposition il
en est une à une il y a beaucoup été
évoquée ce matin c'est celle du patron
du sénat gérard larcher qui a taclé
sévèrement dans les pages de nos
confrères du parisien
la méthode du gouvernement solidaire des
manuels macron avec ces mots l'exécutif
n'a jamais été dans un an en
anticipation
on a l'impression d'un président seul on
vit dans la république de l'oracle
ajoutant jamais on a atteint ce niveau
de verticalité sous la vème république
j'appelle à un changement de méthode
lucile macron doit-il changer de méthode
sans doute mais moi ce qui me frappe
dans les extraits ou dans ce que vous
lisez de gérard larcher c'est le je
pense qu'on est quand même un pays où la
belle formule le théâtre le fait
d'expliquer que tout va mal fait partie
de la culture politique et on le dit
avec une emphase et un vrai talent
oratoire où un talent dans l'entretien
la de gérard larcher
je pas sûr qu'on soit aussi habile avec
les mots ailleurs qu'en france mais là
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
totalement déphasée c'est à dire que par
rapport à ce qu'on disait sur le fait
que certains en parlent d confinement de
ce qui se passe sans le vivre je crois
que les citoyens les français attendent
d'abord des choses assez concret pour
être franche donc à quelque chose sur le
bon sens et le fait de ne pas faire
d'envolées lyriques anti macro sur la
verticalité présidentielle qui est un
fait qui est institutionnel qui emmanuel
macron effectivement exploite à fond
mais je trouve que jean castex avait une
espèce de pour le coup de bon sens de
dire je vous écoute mardi après mardi
fait des propositions qui moi moi moi ça
résonne en moi c'est à dire que pourtant
je suis je suis comme je les dis pour le
pouvoir collectif je suis pour la la
discussion la démocratie mais là je
trouve que c'est pas une vision
démocratique et contre 8,2 pour se poser
je trouve que on le fait surtout avec
des phrases extraordinairement abstraite
grandiloquente alors même que
la question c'est plutôt effectivement
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
vraiment les choses alors j'ai passé
c'est le terrain mais en tout cas il ya
un déphasage entre un discours duo qui
est pas seulement tenu par emmanuel
macron qui est tenus en fait par les
élus la république et par ailleurs
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas un
conseil municipal
je dois le dire donc il ya un pouvoir
exécutif très fort en france on n'est
pas un régime même parlementaire on est
dans un régime présidentiel on n'est pas
comme en allemagne
ce que je voyais que le groupe
socialiste avait dit avait comparé la
situation avec l'allemagne un gala
merkel est lé premier ministre et voilà
elle résulte de la majorité
parlementaire emmanuel macron est élu
directement et sa majorité parlementaire
vient après d'une certaine manière dont
il ya quelque chose d'unique en france
ferait sans doute le changer mais il me
semble qu'il n'ya jamais aucun président
de la république avec une pandémie comme
celle là il ya ça aussi
n'oublions pas que la pandémie c'est
l'urgence donc moi je me sens à la fois
démocrate est déçu par les appels à
l'idée de moins de verticalité qui sont
portés avec un ton une tonalité que je
trouve souvent de mauvaise foi on
s'entraînait qu'est ce que vous répondez
à ces c'est compliqué parce que lui s'il
a raison c'est théâtral et c'était atral
dans tous les sens c'est à dire c'est
théâtrale du côté des manuels macron
d'abord de l'an castex et de ceux qui
qui qui le critiquent et donc on a
vraiment l'impression et moi je pense
c'est un des indes et de l'explication
de la perte de substance de la politique
c'est que la représentation est en train
de l'emporter sur l'action il ya plus
d'action la politique ça n'est plus que
représentait que dire des choses que feu
que que faire des coups d'éclat
une fois qu'on a dit ça moi je suis
plutôt étant attachés à la vème
république et ma généalogie politique je
suis plutôt attaché à un pouvoir qui
serait verticale vous prêt à présent de
lait de l'apli qui décide
il n'empêche que quand on observe les
choses à froid sur cette histoire et
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi depuis l'épisode
de ce matin il ya quand même un problème
c'est à dire que via une espèce de mise
entre parenthèses de la démocratie à
laquelle participent d'ailleurs les
citoyens aussi quand on les interroge
sur est ce que scion desquels les
élections et 10 congrue 100 foot où on a
évacué de la vie
public la conversation civique le débat
la délibération
l'élection c'est quand même des éléments
démocratiques qui sont très importants
et ont lancé habitués au fait que tous
les mois et demi
30 millions de français regardent
l'unique chef de l'état et comme si la
le seul débat politique
maintenant ça consistait à écouter ce
que dit le chef de l'état
puis ce que dira castex pour
l'application pratique est ce que dira
véran pour l'application sanitaire il ya
une forme de passivité aujourd'hui et
bat en tout cas je dis moi je pense ça
n'augure rien de bon et ça peu parce que
ça peut permettre des accidents
électoraux ça peut permettre on l'a un
peu vu aux municipales c'était une
indifférence vis-à-vis des possibilités
du vote qui fait que les élus ne
représente peut-être pas toujours la
population qui qui qui vont ensuite
avoir administré et donc
ca c je vais pas crier au péril
démocratique comme l'a fait je crois que
l'économie ce tout enfin il faut sur la
france je crois pas du tout que que
qu'il ya une tentation chez macron que
de quelle qu'elle soit mais je dis cela
pour de nouveau engagé sur une crête
dangereuse qui remettrait en question la
lame au cra six en tout cas la
démocratie est à l'arrêt et et c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya par exemple il n'y a pas
d' espace médiatique pour une politique
pour une opposition constructive
il y en a pas et il faudrait prendre un
exemple la rue myrha c'est un régime
parlementaire mais quand même churchill
quand il emmène son pays dans la guerre
il le fait au parlement il doit
convaincre le parlement
il doit les faire adhérer et du coup il
entraîne avec lui aussi la population
n'y a pas cette impression que l'on a
d'un pouvoir un peu solitaire et d'une
population qui attend pour savoir assez
pour assortir à 19 heures à 18 heures de
chez elle en tout cas c'est clair que
les oppositions parlementaires l'ont
joué dans l'idée de ne pas prendre part
à ce qu'ils appellent une mascarade et
ce qui était intéressant c'est qu'ils
ont calé que ce soit la droite ou la
gauche l'ont qualifié de mascarade et ça
je peux le comprendre aimer par ailleurs
je me demande si c'était bien jouer
politiquement c'est à dire que je pense
que faire une intervention quelque part
de contenu en expliquant au fond voilà
comment est ce qu'il faut faire voilà ce
que j'aurais fait voilà les propositions
que j'aurais porté ça aurait
certainement déjà réveillé le débat
démocratique dont vincent par l'équipe
que j'appelle de mes voeux serait de
fait et les structures on va bien ce
serait plus constructif et ce serait
peut-être aussi plus de contenu c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui l'obsession macro
nien la haine des manuels macro santé
mais c'est presque une haine personnelle
est quelque chose qui se terminent les
aveux qui entre eux et elle stérilise
notre notre espace démocratique
elles existent dans la société elles
existent au parlement elle est de droite
de gauche et par ailleurs il a aussi une
majorité qui est étrangement godillots
enfin il ya quand même aussi un problème
c'est que n'émergent pas des grandes
figures au sein de ce top ce ce groupe
parlementaire
et ça il faut pas que cette haine
aveuglante d'emmanuel macron nous
empêche de penser que nous aussi nous
devons jouer un rôle politique
ça rejoint ce que dia n'y a que des bras
de fer et des oppositions aucune
mutualisation des efforts pour combattre
la coved c'est dommage
adrienne nous dit non c'est le pouvoir
et sa gestion de la crise qui met en
péril la démocratie
le coc vide a bon dos et enfin en pion à
partir du moment où l'on tremble devant
l'évocation du riz qu on a déjà rompu
avec la démocratie
je passion référendum d'initiative
citoyenne mais il ya un exemple qui
montre les défaillances quand même de
concertation et de et de délibérations
il ya eu un épisode que je crois la
semaine dernière olivier véran à la
télévision lors de la conférence de
presse a expliqué que le maire de cannes
qui avait décidé parce qu'ils avaient
des doutes supplémentaires d'accélérer
sa campagne de vaccination est d'aller
directement vers les plus de 50 ans ne
pouvait pas le faire
elle ne pouvait pas le faire et donc on
a eu un échange le figaro a raconté ça
le maire de cannes à 18 mois le voilà la
vie de liszt arleux
le le présent la république a dit
vacciner matin midi soir ou la nuit le
jour
j'ai des deux je le ferais bon et puis
je crois que finalement les les choses
les choses se sont arrangées
mais il ya hier dans la déclaration de
d'emmanuel macro n'y a pas eu un mot
pour les élus locaux
il n'y a pas eu un mot pour ça il y en a
qui disent quand même se battent depuis
des mois
et donc il ya il ya quand même
l'impression qu'il ya une incarnation au
premier plan et derrière la haute
administration
il ya un sujet dont on a toujours été un
pays où les corps intermédiaires comme
on dit est extrêmement faible c'est à
dire les syndicats les associations
le fait de concevoir les collectivités
locales comme des relais de l'action
publique tout simplement
et ça on voit qu'avec je sais pas si
c'est l'effet d' emmanuel macron mais
c'est le moment où ça se passe et avec
la pandémie cette question
d'articulation d'interaction entre les
corps intermédiaires et le sommet de
l'état n'existe plus là et aussi on sent
moi je j'y tiens à ce sujet on sent au
sein de l'état des divisions profondes
c'est à dire que quand même c'est des
fonctionnaires les soignant à l'hôpital
les la majorité des professeurs et on
sent les tiraillements au sein de l'état
par rapport à ces agents publics et par
rapport au corps politique qui sont
extrêmement forts c'est à dire que
l'absence d'unité de l'état lui même et
je voyais des choses qu'on ressent et au
contraire il faudrait dire que l'état à
mille et une voix et ça permettrait de
diffuser quelque part cette action
publique et on pourrait avoir un état
qui soit 1 étape à mille visages
auquel je tiens beaucoup et qu'on
imagine d'incarner ainsi l'état pas
seulement autour de la figure
présidentielle et ça mon avis c'est un
des grands défis devant lequel on est
parce que pas de corps intermédiaires
pas d'état incarné par le terrain ça ça
explique aussi des loupés qui n'ont rien
à voir avec la personnalité des manuels
macron c'est un système alors par
rapport à la personnalité des manuels
macron et par rapport au fait que vous
avez cités en gala merkel tout à l'heure
on a beaucoup parlé de son intervention
inattendue le 24 mars dernier
de l'autre côté du rhin en allemagne et
ben oui la troisième vague elle prend
aussi de l'ampleur
la chancellière après avoir annoncé un
confinement strict à pâques a décidé de
faire finalement machine arrière elle a
fait son mea culpa et a même demandé
pardon aux allemands angela merkel
décide à plusieurs mais assume seul
est-ce que macron devrait plus
s'inspirer encore parce qu est ce qui se
fait et doit effet angela merkel alors
ce qui est intéressant avec l'angola
merkel est d'ailleurs valérie rabault là
pour le parti socialiste on a parlé à
l'assemblée nationale c'est
qu'effectivement elle a eu une longue
réunion de sept heures mise en scène
avec les ministres présidents des länder
alors il faut quand même savoir que
c'est une réunion qui était informelle
ça correspond pas une réunion
institutionnelle
ce n'est pas au bundestag s'était pas au
parlement et ensuite effectivement elle
a pris sur elle cette responsabilité je
trouve ça d'une très grande habileté
politique c'est à dire qu' elle ne
risquait rien apprendre quelque chose en
termes de responsabilité parce
qu'ensuite il y avait des relais vous
dire que c'est une responsabilité
collective et en assumant ainsi une
décision collective
enfin en fait une non décision
collective elle apparaissait comme une
figure humble le contraire de l'hubris
et je rappelle aussi qu'elle est dans
une situation elle ne se représente pas
donc elle est dans cette situation où on
fait quelque part aujourd'hui elle est
protégée par ce statut où elle ne se
représente pas là beaucoup de liberté et
je trouve que depuis le début de la
crise je sais pas si sa culture
scientifique
elle a eu une espèce d'habileté
permanente à avoir une modestie à mettre
en avant les scientifiques à mettre en
avant d'autres qu'elle est à et sa
popularité a explosé mais ça tient aussi
je tiens à le dire au fait que les
compétences en matière de santé sont
extrêmement différentes en allemagne
c'est à dire que les länder ont beaucoup
de compétences en matière de santé et
elle était obligée de se concerter avec
les ministres présidents des länder
aussi parce que le système est ainsi
chez nous c'est différent c'est l'état
l'hôpital ce sont les agences régionales
de santé ce sont des services
éteint malgré tout vincent trémolet ce
qu'un mea culpa hier d' emmanuel macron
même s'il avait s'il avait moins de
regrets est ce que serait pas un peu
apaisé les esprits
je crois pas parce que d'abord on merkel
ferme à quoi coupable ce qu'elle voulait
faire mais trop fort et on demande à
mâcon de s'excuser de ne pas avoir fermé
assez vite donc ce serait un tout le
contraire en revanche il est certain que
dans notre histoire et de notre histoire
immédiate notamment le premier
confinement avec suspension des travaux
judiciaire suspension des travaux
parlementaires en possibilités des
funérailles des choses qui sont le coeur
d'une civilisation qui n'ont jamais été
même débattu
c'est un problème démocratique et que à
canton je dirais même pas quand on
sortira de sa maintenant il faut y
revenir parce qu'il y a une chose qui
frappe l'est c'est que tous ces trésors
dont on bénéficie et dont le plus
central et la démocratie a été inventé
pour des temps de tempête
pas pour des merdes huile et donc les
mettre entre parenthèses en disant bas
on en parlera plus tard pour l'instant
on attend de vaincre le virus et après
on verra ce qui est à moi la phrase de
jean castex quand il dit
le rapport du conseil scientifique
décidera si on fait les élections tant
on se dit mais il est directeur de
cabinet de jean françois delfraissy au
fait il est pas premier ministre s'est
il ya quelque chose de 2,2 complètement
inadaptée à une confusion désordre
évidemment qu'il faut prendre des
conseils sanitaires
mais il ya un moment le politique doit
décider et par exemple sur la question
de l'élection il eu ce rituel
démocratique qu'on doit tout faire pour
pouvoir le pratiquer parce que sinon ça
va un peu plus désorienté les ex prix et
et je pense que matt ans fernand et que
si ça continue la politique reviendra
par des formes qui seront déplaisante
donc il vaut mieux quand là qu'on la
retrouve avec les formes que nous avons
à notre disposition il y en aura de
nombreuses merci beaucoup et un très
beau les mercis lucile schmid avoir été
aux débatteurs aujourd'hui pour cette
émission je remercie tous ceux qui nous
ont suivis d'avoir participé par
internet sur les réseaux sociaux et
poser vos question est posée et mettre
en ligne vos commentaires à propos de
participation va tout de suite voir ce
que vous avez répondu la crise du commis
de 19 mai tel à l'épreuve la démocratie
en france et vous dit que oui répondez
oui à 71%
merci encore de nous avoir suivi et à
très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]